I want a story about a company that's
gonna be a love story for some a horror
story for a few a fantasy type of story
for others and then obviously a
money-making story for the people that
would involve but people aren't me
telling you the story about this company
I want you to be thinking about two
words shifting habits once again
shifting habits but I'll come back to
those two or two in a minute so let me
take this story about this company it's
1984 a company gets started it's kind of
yellow and a blue logo called
blockbuster blockbusters a great story a
you know you'd go to Blockbuster with
your girlfriend or your husband or your
wife and said yeah we do want to go to
the horse section Oh No maybe comedy no
baby we gotta go to drama and I'm
telling you babe I almost I'm certain
this movie's not gonna be available but
if it is if it's all night tonight
you'd go I know they didn't have it I
don't class the manager the manager may
know because maybe somebody just turned
it in hey John how are you it's us good
to see you John did anybody by any
chance turn in no oh you're so much John
you're always come through thank you
they just dropped it off all thank you
or that family right there dropped it
off it's so great you guys are so
amazing let's take this movie let's buy
some popcorn candy as well an ice cream
let's go that's 1984 they got started by
the way mostly we don't realize
blockbuster only after nine years was
worth eight point four billion dollars
in 1993 by 1997 a company got started
called Netflix it's only worth fifty
million dollars three years later
Netflix 50 million three years later
okay
then at one point blockbuster could have
bought Netflix for 50 million but they
said I just don't think that's the
direction consumer is going to I don't
think they're gonna shift their habits
to this area because people like the
experience of coming to Blockbuster and
actually seeing the DVDs they pick up
nobody wants to just download the movies
not gonna be taking place people are
smarter than that well a hundred and
forty nine million users worldwide
disagreed with them and then Netflix
went from being a 50 million dollar
company in 2002 today
as of just a few minutes ago when I
checked its 147 billion dollar company
by the way blockbuster on September 23rd
2010 went out of business they filed
bankruptcy thing like for nine hundred
and thirty million dollars and they're
gone
solicit immoral the story while Netflix
ins Christmas their stock is up fifty
percent fifty percent just in 2019 in
the first nineteen days of the year
nineteen days of the year Netflix is up
thirty five percent again thirty five
percent
Netflix is up that's a love story for
some a horror story for a few a fantasy
type of story for others and an
obviously money-making story for those
of us that were involved not having said
that what do you mean by shifting habits
look so many people want to be
innovators in the water you know shift
their industry oh my gosh I want to be
in there but I want to be disrupting my
industry luck
Bezos shifted our habits we stopped
going to bookstores to buy books because
he said I'm gonna shift your habit of
the way you buy books
that's why Walmart is afraid of Amazon
right Instagram shifted our habits of
the way we looked at albums when's the
last time you bought an album and the
list goes on and on Google Wikipedia put
encyclopedia companies out of business
how many times you go to Wikipedia to
find out about different things all the
time the moral of the story is this
Netflix shifted our habits and I don't
come you know this thing is about to
come out with Disney flicks or whatever
they want to call it I know one of the
Disney executives said we're not really
trying to compete with Netflix we like
Netflix I use Netflix which is gonna put
out on Marvel products and star wars
products and all this other stuff but
Netflix becomes the one that led the way
and no one even thinks about red box
anymore because red box at first made
sense and by the way if you say I still
use red box you're probably over 40
years old not I'm not trying to offend
you but if you still use red box you're
over 40 you go to Kroger rob's wherever
it is to get to movies look stop trying
to come up with a great idea starts
thinking about shifting habits
not seven Habits of Highly Effective
People shifting cabbage
how do people buy your product how can
you shift that habit
how do people buy the product from you
how can shift that habit and those who
can become the basil's become the sucks
become whatever you want to call it of
their industry because they shifted
someone's have it that's all you got to
be looking at not all this other crazy
fancy stuff so by the way well Facebook
ever be put out of business yes by
somebody who shifts our habit and Zack
says there's no way in the world that's
the direction people gonna go to and
will go that direction
that could also happen to Amazon in
other companies as long as a new
innovator is able to shift our habit
food for thought when you're thinking
about growing your business and taking
it to the next level by the way if you
haven't subscribed to this channel click
on the button below